pour ce deuxième volet de notre page
d'été nous avons rencontré une grande
dame mal an cela a créé des poupées pour
des collectionneuses et s'est reconverti
avec bonheur dans la sculpture et la
peinture
reportage philippe roy laurent blanc
conservés comme des reliques dans leur
boîte d'origine
des poupées de la marque corum des
créations de malouf exporté à travers le
monde ces poupées ont été les
ambassadrices du savoir-faire tricolore
que le souvenir
oui c'est c'est une vie de travail 30
ans peu près 30 35 ans où j'ai fait des
poupées pour les collectionneurs d'abord
et ensuite j'ai fait aussi un peu
d'édition avec l'entreprise corolle qui
a une notoriété importante à travers le
monde
l'entreprise était basé à langer et
voilà j'ai fait j'ai fait une série de 4
coupé avec avec eux plus vrai que nature
fabriqué avec des matériaux nobles elles
sont intemporels c'est une époque où
j'avais vraiment envie de faire des
poupées qui ressemble des petites filles
donc j'ai employé donc je faisais un
modelage de terre
ensuite je faisais un moulage dans
lequel je coulais de la résine et sur
cette tête 7 pouces de positif en résine
je tendais une peau d'agneau
c'est une peau qui savait à faire des
grands elle a des yeux en verre soufflé
donc c'est une très belle très beaux
matériaux aussi et je faisais faire des
perruques ou en mohair comme celle ci
qui fait une chevelure très fine où on
peut faire des choses voilà sera
débouclée où il y avait des aussi des
périodes en jeu fait naturel mais bon je
suis autodidacte j'ai a fait aucune
école d'art donc j'ai beaucoup travaillé
pour apprendre toute une époque révolue
désormais mal ou en cela c'est
résolument tourné vers la peinture et le
moulage
quand je me mets à ma table de travail
le matin je ne sais absolument pas ce
que je vais faire
alors c'est très tout ce qui sort de mes
mains
de ma tête je pense que c'est très lié à
mes centres d'intérêt et à ma façon de
vivre et ça je vis très proche de la
nature je vis assez solitaire et ce
personnage là il est venu parce que j'ai
trouvé cette petite moniteur j'en ai
d'autres que je travaille beaucoup aussi
autour des 2 de tout ce que je trouve
dire que je collecte en marchant dans
mon sac à dos des morceaux de bois les
pierres les plus non et que c'est ça qui
m'inspire c'est là que ça vient tout
seul après je n'ai pas dû je ne sais pas
je sais ce que j'ai fait quand il est
fini voilà j'aime je travaille d'une
manière où je tâtonne beaucoup je rate
eurent beaucoup ça ne va vraiment bien
travaillé comme ça parce que tout d'un
coup je me dis là jour là je suis arrivé
il ya quelque chose qui est juste un
moment donné pour moi en tous les cas
après ce reportage nous retrouvons notre
invité chez elle
parmi ses sculptures et ses peintures on
retrouve aux personnages un peu onirique
un peu effrayant un peu rassurant
beaucoup de personnes y voit quelque
chose du diable ou d'un personnage assez
maléfique et pour moi c'est tout
simplement le gardien de la forêt c'est
un personnage complètement imaginaire
bien sûr qui est protecteur en fait un
personnage protecteur de la forêt je
suis parti d'un tronc d'arbre en fait
et est ce personnage est arrivé tout
seul après portant sur sa tête
les bois de d'un jeune
d'un jeune chevreuil je pense et celle
ci par exemple je vais fait aussi en
revenant d'un endroit où je vais très
souvent près d'un étang brain c'est sa
propre représentent 7 ce lien
ce lien qui petit facile avec les
animaux voilà la seule baisse de
fraternité avec tout le vivant donc les
animaux les végétaux les minéraux et je
pense que c'est aussi ma source
d'inspiration eau profonde au delà des
sculptures il ya des tableaux oui c'est
beaucoup plus récent mais j'ai toujours
eu envie de peindre et comme là aussi je
n'ai pas eu d'apprentissage précis j'ai
beaucoup j'ai rien n'a rien montré
pendant longtemps fait donc je peins
quand même un peu par intermittence j'ai
du mal à parler de mon travail parce que
je ne sais pas ce qui se passe après j'y
vois moi une une harmonie où les quelque
chose de juste pour moi sinon je détruis
ce que je fais voilà merci manouan cela
nous avoir reçus chez vous mixer à vous
notre prochain rendez vous chez un
peintre céramiste devenu sculpteur